joe dispenza is a new york times
best-selling author and an expert in
neuroscience and epigenetics here from
studying biochemistry and neurology
getting a chiropractic degree to
educating thousands on how to rewire
their brains and bodies to make
lasting change and becoming one of the
highest paid speakers in the world
need motivation watch a top 10 video
with believe nation
all my life
hey it's evan carl michael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person that you know
but you also know that you're capable of
more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
joe dispenza and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one break your old habits
we have a huge frontal lobe and it's 40
of our entire brain
and most people uh when they have a
thought they just think that that's the
truth
and i think one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and 90
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
as the day before and you believe that
your thoughts have something to do with
your destiny
your life's not going to change very
much because the same thought leads to
the same
choice the same choice leads to the same
behavior the same behavior creates the
same experience and the same experience
produces the same emotion
and so then the act of becoming
conscious
of this process to to begin to become
more
aware of how you think how you act and
how you feel
it's called metacognition and so then
why is that important because the more
conscious you become of those
unconscious states of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're it means to know thyself
the word meditation means to become
familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self
you're retiring that old self as you
fire and wire new thoughts and condition
the body into a new emotional state
if you do that enough times it'll begin
to become familiar to you so
it's so important uh just like a garden
if you're planting a garden you got to
get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out
the rocks that sift to the top that are
like our emotional blocks they have to
be removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to
we have to make room to plant a new
garden so primarily
we learn the most about ourselves and
others when we're uncomfortable
because the moment you move into that
uncomfortable state normally a program
jumps in when that program jumps in it's
because person doesn't want to be in the
present moment and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life they're less likely to emotionally
react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to
prune synaptic connections and sprout
new connections we have to unfire and
unwire and re-fire and rewire we have to
unmemorize emotions that are stored in
the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram
that's the act and it's a two-step
process rule number two
control your emotional reactions
stronger than the emotion you feel from
some event in your life
be it a betrayal or a trauma or whatever
yes the more altered you feel inside of
you the more you pay attention to the
cause outside of you so the brain takes
a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory
so we create long-term memories from
strong emotional events okay so is that
true i just want to understand
the maybe the larger the event in terms
of its emotion to you the stronger of a
hold it has over you yeah well the more
it's embossed in your biology
so some certain people have a strong
experience in their life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they
think neurologically within the circuits
of the past experience
and they feel chemically within the
boundaries of those emotions and so
how you think and how you feel creates a
state of being now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction
to that event and you keep that
refractory period of chemicals going on
for extended periods of time
so that the event produces a chemical
change and
the body needs to return back to
homeostasis or balance but if it can't
then the elongation of that emotional
reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you
i'm in a mood why are you in a mood well
this thing happened to me five days ago
and i'm having one long emotional
reaction so then what you do is you keep
telling the story about it keep
firing and wiring the same circuits and
you keep conditioning the body into the
past
so then you wake up in the morning you
look for the emotion so that now
all of a sudden you keep it lingering
for for for weeks or months that's
called the temperament well why is he so
angry i don't know let's ask him why are
you so angry well this thing happened to
me eight months ago
i'm having one long emotional reaction
i'm memorizing my emotions
you keep it going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait
so then a person then is memorizing
themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well
tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so
we make stuff up about the past in other
words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have wow
just to reaffirm that they can't change
right wow
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy
period yes so then the stronger the
emotion that you have to some problem or
condition or person in your life
the more you're paying attention to them
so they captured your attention
so you're giving your power away to that
person right because they're capturing
your attention
so then there's an energetic connection
to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides
to be defined by a vision of the future
instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice
so then if you lower the volume to your
frustration
to your hatred to your anger if you
truly
knew how to do that if you lowered the
volume to that emotion you would take
your attention off that person
which means you would begin to break
those energetic bonds and now you're
taking your power back rule number three
be greater than your fears
three types of stress physical chemical
and emotional physical stress
trauma accidents injuries false chemical
stress toxins pollutants heavy metals
blood sugar levels
viruses bacterias mold and then there's
emotional stress which has everything to
do with raising kids and
and second mortgages and single
parenting and time
and and all of those different elements
knock the brain and body out of balance
and the emotional component has always
been the challenging one for most people
because
you could be in a constant state of fear
and consciously or unconsciously
it doesn't matter the food you eat it
won't matter the type of exercise you do
uh if you're living in fear the body is
not in any state
for growth and repair so we have to face
this
one important element and and this is a
time now
where we have to be greater than our
fear rule number four create your own
future
if you're sitting down and you start
thinking about
some future worst case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event
that's taking place in your world our
world and what you're creating by
emotion or thought alone
so most people then they're they're
constantly
reaffirming their emotional states so
when it comes time
to give up that emotion they can say i
really want to do it
but really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way
so the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt
in suffering because at least they can
predict it being the unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain
people say to me well i can't predict my
future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it
not from the known but from the unknown
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day
the act of rehearsing them mentally
closing your eyes
and rehearsing the action they're
rehearsing the reaction of what you want
or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging
and what you're experiencing in 3d world
so then you begin to install the
neurological hardware in your brain
to look like the event has already
occurred now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
now it's a map to the future and if you
keep doing it
priming it that way the hardware becomes
a software program and who knows you
just may start acting like a happy
person
also if you want to have more self love
check out my 254 series it's free
the link to join is in the description
below you were up and dressed and ready
to go before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding to
expect the unexpected
rule number five fully engage in life
i'm not the type of guy who sits in my
house meditating 24 hours a day and
expect things to come to me i'm a
pragmatist i'm a practical person
i'm going to take value and information
i'm going to apply it and see if i can
gain more value from it so
the message is not to sit and meditate
and just receive
universal love and do nothing else
because
my message is to not disengage in life
but to fully engage in life that's my
message
rule number six balance your nervous
system think of your autonomic nervous
system
as the automatic nervous system and i've
been saying for years that
autonomic is synonymous with automatic
and it's that
part of our systems part of our
nervous system that functions behind the
scenes of our awareness and it regulates
body temperature and hormones and blood
supply and blood sugar levels
uh in it and it happens without any uh
uh of our conscious mind so
in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so one
is the sympathetic nervous system and
its job
is for protection from threats and
dangers
in our outer environment and think of
the sympathetic nervous system as the
gas pedal
and when there's a danger to the gross
anatomy of the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our
senses this system is switched on
automatically and once it turns on
there's a host of physiological
functions that begin to happen
automatically and when that occurs we're
mobilizing
all of the body's energy all of the
body's resources
uh for that threat or that danger to
deal with it and and when it's switched
on
uh we don't go half in we go all the way
in because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive
survive in a threat or a danger in the
outer environment
and and when there's a release of all
those adrenal hormones
uh we're tapping the body's resources
and we're mobilizing all of its energy
and pupils dilate salivary juices shut
off
respiratory rate increases heart rate
increases
blood is sent to the extremities glucose
is mobilized
the immune system dials up and then it
dials down and all of these
systems switching on and and turning on
is to be able to allow the body to adapt
to some threat in the outer world and uh
that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system
causes us to really do just a few things
to run
from the danger to fight and stay
or to freeze and hide and those are the
primary choices that we have
created in evolution and so
when the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on and
we as we've been saying for very long uh
for a very long time
uh the short-term effect of
the hormones of stress uh the body can
adapt and return back to balance and it
switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system
called the parasympathetic nervous
system and think of that nervous system
as the break uh or the clutch
this is where the body conserves energy
this is where
utilizes nutrients and and transports
chemicals to cells and metabolism goes
up and and this is a time for growth
this is a time for repair
this is a time for restoration and
there's a delicate balance between the
sympathetic nervous system
and the parasympathetic nervous system
and so then
when you're feeling a constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain
and suffering and you're living by the
hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because
if stress is knocking your brain and
body out of balance and the stress
response is what the body does to return
it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy
for growth repair restoration there's no
energy for long-term building projects
rule number seven go all in crossing
that river of change from the old self
to the new self
there's a neurological a biological
chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side
they won't give up on themselves they'll
keep going so there's enough evidence
to encourage people and you can't tell
me you're too old to do this work
you can't tell me you're too sick to do
this work you can't tell me you had a
turbulent past or or that you're too
overweight or too underweight or too out
of shape or
you can't even tell me that you've never
meditated before in fact some of our
greatest
scams are people who just have never
meditated before that aren't trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible
and they go all in not 50 and not 60
and we do a week-long event we got a
thousand people or 1500 people and they
are
all in and that when they start getting
beyond themselves that first day or
second day
once they start getting beyond
themselves and that magic starts to
happen
then i have no idea i can't predict
what's going to happen next and it's
usually pretty
pretty exciting rule number eight don't
hold grudges
can you speak about the neurophysiology
of forgiveness sure
think about frozen circuits
frozen circuits or hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person that is connected to a
strong
emotion the more the brain
freezes circuitry the more
we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain
yes or no and the more we remember the
event the more we produce the emotions
that are associated with it
and we're conditioning the brain and
body further into the past
yes or no yes and you keep doing it
enough times
it's no longer conscious that you're
holding a grudge
it's no longer conscious that
you're stuck it's now you're seeing
everybody
through the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality
you're not seeing it the way it is
you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception
triggers the emotion in the network and
you're back in your past and you're
acting
like you were when it happened are you
with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this we
all do it
it's just how do we overcome it so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing
the life force into your brain you
are blessing those centers and taking a
scoop
and moving it all the way up and
releasing it all the way up into the
field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding as nobody no one no
thing nowhere in no time and the
identity and the personality is gone
which energy is going to move it's got
to it's going to follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care
it's hard to hold a grudge are you with
me still yes
so then from a quantum physics
point of view you have that person
always in the back of your mind right
you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have
happen you're already preparing for
emotionally
are you with me still so then from a
quantum perspective
you are actually as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage because of that
person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that
experience and you have an energetic
bond that's connecting you to them
and you're sharing the same energy and
so then
you're using each other to reaffirm
whatever that energetic agreement is
are you with me still so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change
in your emotional state because the
emotion is what's keeping you
energetically bound to them
or to more than one person and so then
once you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy
and you're calling your energy back to
you because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person
there comes a moment where there's a
snap there's a release
the energy is broken and once it's
broken now
all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and
this has happened to me in my life the
people
show up 10 years later completely
changed
and so humble and so
asking for forgiveness just because
they had transformed and and i let them
go
so then forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is and when you start
getting happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that
you wouldn't trade this for the grudge
you were holding because this feels too
good
are you with me still now once that
heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing
1300 to 1400 different chemicals
that begin to restore and regenerate the
body the body start getting a lift of
energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending
energy to the brain the heart acts as an
amplifier
to boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you think why would i want to
give this up for that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then when it's released
rushes right into the amygdala the
survival center of the brain and the
research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites
as fear and it lowers the volume to fear
and anxiety it shuts the lights out for
aggression and anger and hostility
and it cools the circuits off for
suffering and pain and the only thing
you can feel
is a love for life and that's when
you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it's
it takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him yeah
[Music]
halfway forgive him and just never
really authentic forgiveness do you
understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager and it was
abusive
and she had severe
severe night terrors severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to
every single doctor every single healer
every single
alternative practitioner nothing changed
it
she came to our event in
in um tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone
everything everywhere every time every
place she became the oneness
in the and that frequency had a message
for her and it said
and she was an incredible bliss when
this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors that
was the end
of her night she couldn't have a
relationship she couldn't she could not
live with anybody she was she was
isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message
and she got the download not just that
not just the thought she got the energy
moved right through her body
and she saw the whole thing and that
moment is what she was waiting for
that's what the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy
and she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life reborn
in the same life didn't pass through a
birth canal for it
she just was born again in the same life
she got a new lease in
one instant that energy was carrying
a message and it made its way all the
way into the body
and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried with
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the divine having its way with
you rule number nine
change your beliefs most people
are waiting for their life the change
yes so they can feel gratitude to feel
abundance to feel
whole you know that's the old model of
cause and effect you know
so if you're living with emptiness
you're living with lack you're living
with pain
most people have been conditioned that
something out there
has to take away this emptiness or
feeling inside of them but
if you believe that you're creating your
life and you're living by lack well lack
is going to create abundance right
so so then it makes sense then that
you don't really actually create wealth
you generate wealth you generate
abundance so
the moment you start teaching your body
emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind
believes it's living in that future in
the present moment now
it's the scientific fact that it's the
environment that signals the gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that
well genes make proteins and proteins
are responsible for the structure
and the function of your body and the
expression of proteins is the expression
of life
so by you creating an elevated emotion
and teaching your body what that future
will feel like
before it's made manifest your body's
starting to live in that future reality
in the present moment now here's the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom
and you're able to generate those
chemicals every single day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen
you would already feel like it has
happened now what is the importance of
that
well you're literally becoming somebody
else so you're leaving your lack
you're leaving your guilt you're leaving
your emptiness behind your personality
literally yet is made up of how you
think how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life
so then if you want to change your life
your personal reality
you got to change your personality and
here we go again you got to start
becoming conscious of your unconscious
thoughts
you got to start noticing how you act
how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them
so then when you start doing that you
begin to objectify your subjective self
so
so then when you begin to make small
changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice
a new choice should lead to a new
behavior a new behavior should create a
new experience and a new experience
should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body
chemically to understand what your mind
is intellectually understood now your
body is embodying the truth
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is hardwire your brain i believe in
human possibility human potential and i
think that one of our biggest
limiting beliefs is the belief have how
limited we really are
and so my interest is to give people
the science to begin to understand how
powerful they really are
and i think that science really is the
language that does that really well and
in the new sciences like quantum physics
and uh
neuroplasticity neuroscience neuro
endocrinology you know
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all
of those sciences point the finger at
possibilities so
i want to create a language for people
from a philosophical or theoretical
standpoint
for them to begin to understand what's
possible
but then i want to be able to have those
people begin to wire that information in
their brain completely because learning
is making new connections right in the
brain
but remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections and it's so
much easier
to lose our vision than to remember it
right so then we have to begin to
hardwire the brain or install the
neurological hardware
in preparation for an experience so the
more people understand what they're
doing and why
then the how gets easier so i want to
then set up the conditions
in an environment in a in a in a
workshop where people can begin to
apply or personalize what they learn so
that they can have an experience an
experience then further enriches the
brain but
the prize of an experience is an emotion
and once you start feeling unlimited
once you start feeling abundant once you
start feeling worthy
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so
knowledge is for the mind and
experiences for the body and people
begin to embody the truth
of that philosophy now if they can
repeat it over and over again
it'll become innate in them and become
natural second nature become easily
begin to
master that philosophy so i want people
to
begin to understand that thoughts are
very powerful feelings drive our
thoughts
and that they can begin to create a
better life for themselves once they
understand some of these
principles now i've got a special bonus
gift from joe on how to be
hungry that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i wanna know where do you need to go all
in let me know put it down in the
comments below and if you made it this
far in a video you're still here
watching
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below i want to celebrate you
we don't just
watch videos here we do something about
it so give me that believe
in the comments below too fifteen twenty
years ago
um everybody wanted to stay in the
philosophical realm nobody wanted to do
anything with it but this is
this is the time in history where it's
not enough to know this is a time in
history to know how
because information is so available
right i mean
you don't need a doctor you don't need a
priest you don't need a rabbi
you don't need a governor you don't need
a teacher to gain information need an
authority any longer
because of technology we have access to
information well information
creates awareness and awareness is
consciousness
and you can't have consciousness without
energy so people are beginning to wake
up with a greater level of awareness of
what's possible so
15 years ago 20 years ago 10 years ago i
walked out and there was
always a little resistance but now
people are coming because they want to
actually experience the truth of it so
that makes my job easier because i can
just walk out
and just fire away because people are
prepared
they're informed they're ready so
anything that's not consistent with that
energy or that level of awareness
those paradigms are beginning to break
down whether it's education whether it's
religion whether it's politics economics
the environment the medical model
everything is collapsing because people
are informed
so i love that idea because when people
show up and they say well listen
i understand that i have a health
condition i understand that it's taken
me
10 years of being unhappy 10 years of
living in stress
10 years of living in fear that's
actually
begin to signal or select and instruct
the gene that creates the disease
well it may take me some time then to
unlearn that process to break that
conditioning process so there's a
practical understanding now but
something amazing has happened i mean
we've spent over 10 years
doing very advanced scientific studies
we've done
over 8 500 brain scans we've measured
so many thousands of hearts because if
you're going to create a new future
it requires a clear intention and
elevated emotion well
let's train our people how to create
really
really high level brain coherence and
really really really self-regulating
heart coherence why
because if you're going to believe in
that future that you're creating with
all of your heart
it better be opened and activated and
you better know how to do that and you
better understand the science of what
happens
we've measured a gene regulation 7500
different gene regulations we know you
can change your gene expression in four
days we've measured it you're not
you're not doomed by your genes you're
your own genetic engineer that
that um you can lengthen your life and
we've seen telomeres actually lengthens
60 days of meditation that you you add
days
your life you're changing your genetic
future that you can strengthen your
immune system by thought alone that's
that's that's the evidence from the
scientific perspective and people
love the evidence because they start to
see that's possible
you're not going to find that in a
pharmaceutical commercial you're not
going to find that
out there in the world you got to really
be hungry and look for it
so then that sets the stage for the
person to come and want
to have that experience there may not be
so quick
to say hey i want to heal my body right
away they may say
i need to get my brain heart coherent
first and i got to begin to put my
effort into learning how to do this like
learning any skill
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer
on this channel i have a dedicated brand
new channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out continue to believe
and i'll see you there